mein thema ist ich habe mich aufgeregt
über tatsächlich war angela merkel tue
ich selten aber in diesem fall schon
weil die hat ja in einer nacht und
nebelaktion die spitzenvertreter der
neuen ampel regierung ins kanzleramt
geholt und um mit ihnen zu sprechen in
chur wohnanlage und die wir über bild
erfahren haben heute ja auch über einen
neuen look dauern das war viel zu
spielen denn ich bin fest davon
überzeugt wir werden einen neuen job
bekommen denn die intensivstation laufen
voll und wir sehen an den steigenden
zahlen dass wir sicherlich in zehn oder
14 tagen volle identifikation mit vielen
vielen corona patienten noch mehr als
heute bekommen werden
jetzt kann man natürlich sagen angela
merkel hat mit ihrem versuch ihr
daraufhin leiten wollen und mit ihrer
warnung für eine verschärfung der lage
doch recht behalten und recht machen
sind das völlig gegensätzliches in der
politik und die immerwährende
beschreibung von defiziten reicht
einfach nicht aus um von vorne zu führen
denn angela merkel hat im sommer handeln
müssen als sie nach eigener aussage
schon erkenntnisse vor die arten wie
sich die entwicklung
weiter die entwicklung weitergehen
werden wird und sie hätte impfstoff von
ihrem gesundheitsminister zusätzlich
organisieren lassen müssen sie hätten
das buch dann beginnen müssen und sie
hätte gleichzeitig auch dafür sorgen
müssen dass diese in zentren offen
bleiben und nicht geschlossen werden
obwohl sie hätte vielleicht auch weil
ich dann einen biologen wie herrn
drosten der noch vor drei monaten
erklärt hat es reiche völlig aus über 70
jährige zu boostern der westseite
geschützt durch die tollen impfstoffe in
die schranken weisen müssen auch
öffentlich doch von ihr kann nichts nada
niente was führung auszeichnete in
dieser wichtigen endphase der vierten
oder anfangsphase der vierten stelle
über angela merkel heißt ist immer sie
führt vom ende her und das sei so toll
aber das macht sie nicht richtig ist
sich regiert vom ende her doch wer immer
nur vom ende her regiert die korona
maßnahmen da ist die flüchtlingskrise
oder auch fukushima der ist ziemlich
schnell selbst am ende mit seinem latein
ich würde da fast noch einen drauf
setzen weil mich das genau so geärgert
hat und weil ich also regelrecht
darunter leide
die das verhalten der kanzlerin
allerdings auch derjenigen die dort eine
regierung bilden
ist es verdruckst da kommt nichts
richtiges es fehlt mir die linie und die
pandemie zeigt eigentlich wie wichtig
eine stringente führung ist und auch
eine konsequente führung dass man sagt
ich habe keine gesicherte erkenntnis an
dieser stelle das kann man ja so nennen
die die vielstimmigkeit der virologen
gehört ja dazu aber nicht jeder hat eine
wahrheit und das verunsichert und dass
man es im grunde genommen so lauwarm
weitertreibt wir stehen hier vor einer
situation die ja dramatisch als wenn ich
das richtig sehe als vor zwölf monaten
und jeder hätte sie eigentlich kommen
sehen müssen aber wenn wir jetzt über
das ganz konkrete sprechen da finde ich
muss man doch sagen macht es doch sinn
dass je nachdem wie hoch die inzidenz
hospitalisierung rate sterberate ist das
dann in den verschiedenen regionen
entschieden werden kann ob es anlockte
und gibt ja oder nein das passiert ja
schon in sachsen teilweise das passiert
in bayern möglicherweise das kann doch
jedes bundesland jeder ministerpräsident
ich würde sogar noch weiter gehen und
sagen am ende der der landrat oder der
oberbürgermeister in regionen wo die
inzidenz wirklich in die 800.000 geht
würde ja wahrscheinlich jeder
vernünftige mensch sagen okay können wir
gut spielen aber deutschlandweit wieder
so ein locker und zu verhängen bilder
das ist doch auch für all diejenigen die
sich geimpft haben die gesagt hat in
diesem winter wird alles anders jetzt
lassen wir noch boostern jetzt sollen
die noch mal bestraft werden für die
nächsten wochen und sagen sperren euch
wieder ein natürlich ist das eine strafe
bauern aber wir sehen noch die realität
klar es wäre das beste wenn die regionen
die ministerpräsidenten vielleicht sogar
um noch weiter runter gebrochen dann
auch die landkreise selbstständig
entscheiden und sagen im lok drankommt
die realität ist aber es muss er ist
muss nicht fünf nach zwölf sein es muss
zwei sein damit die erstmalig das mal
etwas salopp in die hufe kommen und
einen solchen lockdown glauben möglich
machen zu können weil es eben diese
berechtigten widerstände gibt die leute
fertig sind nach zwei jahren sei sie
sagen was soll denn das jetzt haben sie
uns gesagt lasst euch zweimal impfen
jetzt und man muss da rein wozu denn das
ich habe gedacht wir sind damit
geschützt den muss man ja erst einen
bundesweiten lockt an ich habe bin ich
dafür ich glaube er wird kommen und so
oder so
und da sei die politik die wahrheit sagt
politik hätte vorher handeln müssen
länder fördern nicht natürlich bin ich
dafür ja weil ich sehe dass die zeiten
die zahlen wir haben jetzt 70.000 du
kannst doch rechne in zehn tagen werden
von den 70.000 ein gewisser prozentsatz
in den intensivstationen liegen und die
intensivstationen überschwemmen ich bin
ehrlich wir dürfen niemals mehr locker
und haben in diesem land und wir müssen
uns auch mal ganz ehrlich sagen ich
empfinde unsere hunde da auch ich kann
es auf jeden fall über mich sagen als
immer furchtbar und dann zeigen wir den
leuten reden weil das schöne ist ja
sollte er lockt da sein werden je wieder
sitzen wir dürfen ja senden auch im
lockdown ich kann meinen job auch
ausführen das heißt für mich ist es
immer so toll der lektor und journalist
vollen dass auch alle die journalisten
übrigens diese immer alle fordern sind
die dauernd interviews machen ob es am
telefon machen die arbeiten können es
fordert andauernd einen klasse die
arbeiten kann übrigens auch politiker
können auch arbeiten aber wenn menschen
ihren job ihr job genommen wird wir
müssen darüber wirklich mal reden das
kann nicht schon wieder passiert ist
kann ich seine wieder nicht arbeiten
dürfen das heißt es geht jetzt darum
wird eine klare sprache gesprochen und
wird konsequent gehandelt man kann auch
dass wenn man sagt ich will keinen lockt
dann soll man es verdammt noch mal
erklären das ist was mir zu wenig
passiert politik wird nicht erklärbar
gemacht und das geht jetzt ja nicht um
irgendeinen zusatz katalysator sondern
es geht um unser zusammenleben und da
kann man meiner meinung nach gar nicht
genug erklären und spindoktoren run
holen und die verschiedenen positionen
darstellen weil es komplett elementar
ist aber wir gerade sehen in der runde
ich finde aber dieser vorwurf der muss
zu großen teilen auch aufs konto von
olaf scholz gehen denn jetzt kann man
natürlich sagen ja klar angela mehr das
geschäfts für eine bundeskanzlerin ja
alles richtig aber sie sieht natürlich
im moment wie groß die problemlage ist
und ich glaube niemand wünscht sich
irgendwie einen locken aber wir sehen
dass die zahlen sich dramatisch
entwickeln bin ich eine analyse ganz
genau dabei wenn ich jetzt heute wieder
sehe wenn ich mit den krankenhäusern
telefoniere bei mir im wahlkreis wenn
ich mit meinem landrat telefonieren
beängstigende zustände was da auf uns
zukommt und die kanzlerin sagt ich muss
jetzt noch etwas tun und olaf scholz der
jetzt dann als bundeskanzler übernehmen
soll der hat sich dann das schöne die
deckung gibt übergeben und das ist sag
ich mal auch nicht die frage wie man
sich dann verantwortungs wahrnehmung
vorstellt denn es geht nicht dass die
ampel sagt sie beschließt das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz im bundestag und
wie es denn jetzt weiter geht das soll
einmal die geschäftsführende kanzlerin
ohne mehrheit im parlament machen das
funktioniert ja auch nicht also ihre
meinung ist auch das müsste sofort
sofort etwas passieren und es müsste
lockdown bundesweit nein ich bin
jedenfalls bin ich da nicht der experte
der den blick darauf hat wie die lösung
aussehen kann aber teil zumindest die
besorgnis die béla anda beschreibt in
der frage wie sich die pandemie weiter
entwickelt also sollen sie für einloggen
oder dagegen also ich kenne jetzt nicht
den vorschlag den die bundeskanzlerin da
gemacht hat und ich glaube auch in der
beschreibung sind wir eigentlich sein
auto ja oder nein ist er nicht so schwer
ja also wir müssen sehen was heißt denn
das locker und whatever disney ja das
ist jetzt ein einfacher begriff den man
dann in
das das den menschen die freiheit ja
sowieso genau wie du hast den bayern
sind die weihnachtsmärkte abgesagt er
arbeitet aber keiner mehr die waren sind
eingekauft die leute die arbeiten sollen
arbeiten eben nicht die diskotheken
machen zu der arbeitet auch keiner mehr
ab 22 uhr machen die gasthäuser zu der
arbeitet auch keiner mehr also das ist
doch überhaupt nicht flächendeckend
geschlagen das wird aber so kommen weil
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass bei
so und incidents werden und dies ist es
ja auf den farbigen karten dass die 1
liga glaubt dann kommt ist das ein
absolutes armutszeugnis für dieses land
weil wirklich wenn wir jetzt fast zwei
jahre nach der wende kein anderes ist
als ein lock down haben und er darf
nicht kommen ich bin wirklich der
meinung was ist der preis wenn man
menschen ihre träume nimmt auch das
hatten preis und mit viel zu wenig
darüber redet alles ist erlaubt alles
ist dieser pandemie erlaubt nicht allen
wird alles genommen und ich bin der
privilegierten lage ich habe den leuten
ehrlich sehr gut ertragen können weil
ich ja immer arbeiten konnte aber ich
finde aus dieser position die ich da
auch habe glücklicherweise heraus zu
sagen den brauchen willst ich bin
wirklich komplett ergeben und in mercks
meine weine ich bin wenn ich nur daran
denke schon hinüber an karl lauterbach
oder den lockt aber über ein punkt noch
zu beruhigen hat man natürlich sagen
rechtlich gibt es auch gar keine
handhabe dafür dass jetzt irgendwie der
bundeseinheitliche locker und sofort
kommt das ginge nur aus jetziger
überzeugung mit einer weiteren änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes sind
deswegen muss man auch sagen so
holterdiepolter mal ich muss mal alle
zusammen und wir machen den locker und
das für rechtlich nicht